- Les corridors sont
comme des labyrinthes.
Il y a du monde partout,
le va-et-vient est constant,
chaque étage se ressemble :
du linge, des enfants qui
courent.
Ils sont 1253 Ukrainiens
à bord de ce village flottant,
un immense bateau de croisière
ancré au port de Tallinn
pour héberger temporairement
les rescapés de la guerre
en Ukraine.
Irina est arrivée à
la mi-octobre, tout simplement
soulagée d'être en vie. Elle
s'est habituée très rapidement
à vivre dans quelques mètres
carrés avec ses petits.
Elle habitait à Enerhodar, où
elle et son mari travaillaient
comme contrôleurs de la qualité
de l'air à la centrale nucléaire
Z Zaporijia, sous occupation
russe. Constamment surveillée
et fouillée, elle avait peur
d'être kidnappée comme l'ont
été nombreux de ses voisins.
Comme tant d'autres, elle
a dû faire un choix déchirant :
quitter l'Ukraine, mais le faire
par la Russie.
"On a étudié toutes
les options, mais c'était
la seule possible", dit-elle,
rattrapée par le stress d'avoir
eu à parcourir plus de 2000 km
en territoire ennemi pour
arriver ici en Estonie.
Des hommes nous ont confié
avoir été soumis à
des fouilles humiliantes
dans ce qu'on appelle
les centres de filtration
pour rentrer en Russie,
où ils sont séparés des femmes
et interrogés par les services
de sécurité russes, le FSB.
Dmytro raconte comment
des agents du FSB l'ont traité
quand il est arrivé en Crimée,
passage obligé.
Des heures d'humiliation
à faire des push-ups, même,
et a plaidé, bien malgré l,,
son allégeance à la Russie.
Menr,r, c'est la seule façon
de s'en sortir.
Les autorités estiment
qu'au moins deux millions
d'Ukrainiens ont été forcés
comme lui d'entrer en Russie
pour sortir de leur pays.
Un exode de masse que
le gouvernement de l'Ukrnene
considère comme une déportation
masquée de ses citoyens,
qui n'ont plus de toit
ou plus rien à manger.
Dmytro dit que plieieurs de
ses amis ukrainiens se sont,
en effet, résignés à s'installer
à Moscou, parce qu'on leur offre
de l'aide  d de l'argent,
mais ça lui donne mal au coeur.
Sa ville, c'était Marioupol.
Il lui reste des photos
du squelet d de ce qui était
leur appartement, le salon,
la cuisine, la chambre de
sa fille.
Il y a sur ce bateau
tatant d'histoires de survie que
d'histoires d'horreur, des gens
qui refusent de les raconter
à la caméra, de peur que
leurs proches soient punis,
car ils sont encore, soit
sous occupation en Ukraine,
ou coincés ici à la frontière
russe, en attendant de traverser
en Europe.
Il n'y a pourtant que
200 mètres qui séparent
des centaines de réfugiés
de l'Estonie, mais plusieurs
ONG rapportent que les douaniers
russes les sortent des autobus
et les font attendre des jours
dans le froid ou sous la pluie
avant de les laisser parti
C'est souvent ici que
les interrogatoires sont
les plus corsés, derrière nous,
mais tout le monde nous dit
la même chose : une fois qu'on
traverse ces grilles blanches,
après des mo d d'occupation
russe, après des mois de cavale,
on peut enfin respirer
comme il faut.
C'était une délivrance pour
Serguey, qui a payé des passeurs
300 $ pour sortir de personnes
juste avant  r référendum
au mois d'octobre.
"Le pire, pour moi,
c'était de traverser la Russie
et d'être interrogé, dit-il.
J'étais terrorisée,
je me suis dit : qu'est-ce que
je peux faire pour m'assurer
de m'en sortir indemne?"
"J'ai tout effacé
de mon téléphone."
Il a fait tout ce qu'il avait
à faire pour éviter d'être
arrêté par le FSB : éliminer
les applications des nouvelles
occidentales,  l la BBC,
des nouvelles ukrainiennes,
en fait, de prétendre qu'il
écoutait la propagande russe.
"Parce que je sais, dit-il,
ce qui arrive aux hommes
qui affichent leur soutien
à l'Ukraine dans les campsde fi"
Des hommes comme Igor,
dont le tatouage aux couleurs
de l'Ukraine qu'il portait
sous sa bague lui a valu d'être
arrêté et transporté de force
dans un camp de détention.
Pendant un mois, il a dormi
au sol sur une planche de bois
avec d'autres compatriotes.
C'est là, en cachette,
qu'il a décidé de brûler
son tatouage avec du charbon
pour s'en sortir vivant,
retrouver ses proches
et recommencer à zéro en Europe.
Et pour chaque famille
qui quitte le bateau,
une autre doit arriver.
Cet autobus est arrivé
à Tallinn ce soir, mais
sans les réfugiés qui étaient
popourtant à bord quelques heurs
plus tôt, quand il a quitté
Saint-Pétersbourg.
On nous dit qu'ils ont été
retenus à la frontière russe,
on ne sait pas pour combien de
temps. Leur chambre les attend,
mais leur sort repose entre
les mains de la Russie.